[Música]
porque hay escasez de anticonceptivos en
colombia los médicos se encuentran
preocupados debido a que el cambio de
medicamento además necesita un tiempo
puede afectar a los pacientes digamos y
hay que cambiarlo porque no se encuentra
uno que ya el paciente estaba tomando
anteriormente sin embargo la denuncia se
remonta a finales de 2021 cuando se va a
conocer que varias marcas de fármacos ya
no se conseguían en el país y que al
parecer dejaron de ser fabricadas además
de problemas en los insumos para poder
producir los diferentes medicamentos o
hormonales las consecuencias no sólo son
los embarazos no deseados las personas
que no quieren tener hijos sino también
problemas de salud que producen estos
cambios hormonales debido a la
interrupción de estos anticonceptivos
para pues las mujeres además el gremio
farmacéutico confirma este
desabastecimiento de las píldoras
anticonceptivas en la nación y para ello
entonces conversamos con nuestro segundo
invitado del día nos acompaña en el
estudio él es alfonso cultiva presidenta
de la junta directiva nacional de la
asociación colombiana
y detallista alfonso bienvenido muy
buena mañana de miércoles gracias buenos
días de raúl iván y la teleaudiencia así
es también nos acompaña como ustedes ya
pues es la hoy hoy la salud más romeros
a la nuestra periodista especializada en
salud después alfonso quisiera empezar
hablando de ésta este desabastecimiento
de anticonceptivos de qué magnitud
estamos hablando y si realmente es un
tema que ya debería empezar a tocar no
sé si la autoridad digamos nacional en
colombia o que se está haciendo para
para contrarrestar de este
desabastecimiento
bueno raúl hay que decir que esto no es
de ahorita esto esto comenzó hace unos
años ya
y hay varios factores que desde ese
tiempo han venido incidiendo
comenzando por lo obvio la pandemia
pero luego eso fue llevando una cosa a
la otra
la pandemia impactó el transporte de
materias primas a nivel mundial debido a
que a que como es bien sabido hay
escasez de contenedores entonces hay
materia prima pero no tenemos en que
llevarlos el primer factor y luego viene
otro factor
qué impacto también toda vez que el
estado
involucro incluyó los productos
anticonceptivos en control de precios
directos por parte del estado entonces
hay que recordar que hace unos años
alguna marca de anticonceptivos
tranquilamente podría valer 60 mil pesos
y bajó a 10 mil 12 mil pesos en ese
momento 20 mil pesos de modo que esta
asignación de precios por parte del
estado se hizo con base en estudios
internacionales y en su momento el dólar
estaba alrededor de 3 mil pesos o menos
hoy está bordeando los 4600 pesos
de modo que esto impacta también la
producción o por lo menos hace que la
industria
mire con más detalle donde colocan sus
productos y es obvio al fin y al cabo la
industria farmacéutica es un negocio
de modo que ellos colocan sus productos
donde mejor rentabilidad tengan entonces
ahí en este momento la volatilidad de la
moneda también está influyendo en este
tema pero a mí me parece importante
recordar que américa latina es de las
regiones con una tasa de embarazos
adolescentes por ejemplo más altos donde
sabemos que embarazos no deseados son
una de las causas a veces también del
propio empobrecimiento de la población
entonces esa regulación de precios
podría aparecer como una buena medida de
salud pública digamos para hacer más
accesibles los tratamientos
anticonceptivos creo que hay alguna
forma de mantener esa regulación de
precios pero también haciendo atractivo
pues al mercado farmacéutico para que se
sigan vendiendo y se sigan consiguiendo
estos tratamientos aquí en colombia la
norma y adicionalmente también proteger
digamos a estas mujeres que
evidentemente no tienen los recursos
económicos para comprar una pastilla
anticonceptiva entonces también algún
tipo de plan social que se pueda pues no
dejar desprotegida a las personas que
desean seguir con sus tratamientos
anticonceptivos en pastillas por ejemplo
claro algunos datos
el
51% de la población colombiana son
mujeres
y de estas mujeres alrededor del
50% de la población de mujeres están en
edades entre los 15 y los 49 años que es
la edad
reproductiva de manera que
esto es un problema que hay que mirarlo
de los dos lados como hago para cumplir
con la obligación primaria del estado
que es atender esta problemática de
embarazos prematuros sabemos que eso fue
un problema de salud pública aquí y
niñas de 12 años en adelante en
situación de embarazo de modo que ahí la
educación sexual y el acceso a los
anticonceptivos pues se hace
fundamental
de modo que hay que mirar el problema me
parece a mí
desde una mesa de diálogo no solamente
que el estado regule sino que además sea
como el resultado de una mesa de diálogo
donde se analice a profundidad el
problema para cumplir con las dos cosas
que se pueda proteger a la población que
se pueda atender eso es lo primario pero
que la industria lo puede hacer sin
perder dinero por supuesto sino que debe
ser una cosa equilibrada equitativa de
modo que me parece que una mesa de
diálogo en la que este estado ministerio
de salud esté en la industria al menos
los que quienes producen los
anticonceptivos y por supuesto los
gremios el caso nuestro estar presente
porque estoy convencido que es la
solución porque a través del diálogo es
que se pueden establecer claramente las
problemáticas y por supuesto encontrar
las vías de solución a las mismas de
manera que me parece que es importante
acometer una tarea como esto por
supuesto y evidentemente ese mes hay
algo pues no se ha logrado alfonso
no estamos teniendo acercamientos con el
ministerio de salud pero aquí hay otra
coyuntura adicional no ayer por ejemplo
teníamos una cita con en el ministerio
de salud con con una funcionaria y
resulta que cuando llegamos pues
tuvieron que asignar a otro funcionario
porque ella estaba ahí en un proceso de
empalme claro entonces tenemos ese otro
inconveniente que ahorita hay hay
quienes están saliendo y hay quienes
están entrando entonces a ver
con que nos vamos nos vamos a entender
estamos sí sí sí sí que asume el yermo
de bernando exactamente una vez
establecido esto pues se podrá atender
de manera adecuada yo quería preguntarle
también ampliando un poquito la mirada
sabiendo que esta crisis pues no afecta
solamente a colombia al menos la crisis
de suministros de la que estaba hablando
ni la pandemia han sido problemas
globales usted ya con la experiencia de
lo que está sucediendo aquí en colombia
sabe si podría suceder que se extendiera
este problema de falta de abastecimiento
de anticonceptivos a otros países de la
región
esperemos que sí esperemos que ahora que
algunos países han declarado ya el fin
de la emergencia sanitaria colombia es
uno de ellos pero también hay otros que
están mirando es como vuelven a volver a
ser confinamiento si eso es debido a los
picos que se empiezan a presentar
entonces ahí se presenta ese
inconveniente hay otra cosa por comentar
y es que algunas materias primas para la
producción de estos productos vienen de
países que están en conflictos claro
entonces ahí encontramos otro otro gran
obstáculo a salvar o sea digamos lo que
sería por ejemplo la guerra en ucraniano
corrientemente pues allá obviamente toda
esta crisis de suministros eso se va
afectando aún más para agravar la
problemática de los anticonceptivos no
sé si martín es alguna pregunta ya como
para finalizar nuestra conversación nos
quedan 30 segunditos sólo finalizando
que cuáles son estas materias que vienen
de ucrania ustedes sabe cuál es esta
materia que falta de que viene para
hacer estos anticonceptivos
he visto investigando un poquito que
estas hormonas las extraen de algunos
cereales
tenemos de modo que es conocido que
estos países que están en conflicto son
de los mayores productores de cereales
en el mundo